1.59
era in his rookie season what a year
it's been for him
garcia batting 255 up the middle back to
kk
he'll spin and throw for the outs
christian yelich went one for
nine ground ball backhanded
the flip to kim and that's out number
two corbin burns out on the hill
yeah he's on a roll he's only giving up
one earned run in his last five
draws the walk to lead off edmond the
switch hitter batting from the
left side of the plate
and a cold strike three on the outside
edge
three and two on goldschmidt burns
throws struck him out swinging
there's the cutter on the outside corner
he notches his second strikeout
so two down long still at third and
here's matt carpenter again the 2-2
swing and a miss and burns gets through
the first
and a runner left at third for st louis
swaying and a miss and a strikeout in
the first
for kk he gets jerko who has been
destroying left-handed pitching this
year here's tyrone taylor
2-1 on the ground could be two out there
the turn
double play and yadi just two hits away
and
just so excited for him that's going to
be a special moment for him
just a little chopper left side can he
beat it out
and he will he is one hit shy of 2000
in his career the base hit for yadier
molina
so molina advances to third miller to
second
and it's up to the rookie dylan carlson
this one popped up kristin yelich gets
underneath it and makes the catch
for the final out corbin burns with a
little foot traffic against him
but strands two cardinals on base
so burns has had to throw 46 pitches to
get through two
kim at 31 here in the third good pitch
in on his hands and the brewer is not
able to advance the runner to third
now jacob noddingham swaying and a miss
and a strikeout of nottingham so after
the leadoff double
back-to-back strikeouts for kk
and the cardinals will have first and
third paul goldschmidt
shift on the left side goldie lines it
into center that is down for a base hit
and a run will score
and it's one nothing cardinals the
redbirds strike first thanks to paul
goldsmith
three consecutive singles here in the
third against burns
here's molina long two strikes and
molina
strikes out there's that cutter he found
at best one
so two aboard with two down here in the
fourth here's tyrone taylor
here's the 2-2 and this one into
left-field base hit
and jerko rounds third and
is in to tie the game at 1-1 there you
go
three hits in the inning who was able to
scratch out a run
oh there's your hit with a man in
scoring position there you go
first pitch offered to paul deyoung is
hit out to left field and racing back
and making the catch on the warning
track
is christian yelich the young got into
that one but
maybe the best news there is that it was
one pitch and one out for corbin burns
who has
racked up a high pitch count through the
first three innings but he gets a quick
out there
and runner has reached base in all four
innings for the cardinals
now dylan carlson flied to left with two
runners on
back in the second inning and carlson
hits a high
fly ball out to deep right field it's at
the wall it is gone
dylan carlson high towering shot
he kept it fair a two run homer for the
rookie
3-1 st louis towering
home run to right field his third
of his rookie season and he knew it he
knew he had the distance
and would it stay fair you bet it did i
think that's going to be it
there's something up with him he wanted
to stay in and
burns very frustrated and will walk off
the field
and be done for the night four and
two-thirds innings for
corbin burns and he will leave drilling
three to one
this is not what anyone would have
anticipated here as well as corbin burns
has been pitching
going into this game lead off walking
here's dylan carlson
he's not running and that's lifted in
the air slicing into the gap
in left center field that ball is down
one hopper off the wall
gets away here comes fowler racing to
the plate
no throw dexter follow will score and
dylan carlson is driven in three
4-1 cardinals well carlson showed his
power to right field now we've seen it
to left-center and the cardinals got a
good
bounce off the wall that allowed dexter
fowler to
score here comes molina his teammates
watching
intently from the dugout molina serves
it into right center
there it is hit number 2 000
for yadier molina the 12th catcher
in the history of major league baseball
with 2
000 hits one of the greatest ever to put
on a cardinals uniform
and there it is hit number 2
000 for yachty and that was not a cheap
one he hit that one right on the nose
and he's all smiles he knew it
right away and the cardinals dugout just
erupts
they know how important he is to them
to the cardinal franchise and now
baseball history
two pinch hit singles here in the ninth
for the brewers two on
tying run at the plate one two on the
way and sogar down the line
fairball in comes peterson
oglebach has to stay out at second base
the brewers now within four to two and
one
more to go and he's not an easy guy to
get
3-2 he struck him out
miller strikes out yelich and the
cardinals take game one of the series
4-2